je vous emmène chez Adrien simmerai
cette yvelinois habite à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et a fondé
péloche moi il vous propose de réparer
vos vieux appareils photos argentiques
alors l'argentique ça permet vraiment de
faire des photos qui sont différentes
assez souvent on va le comparer au
numérique pour moi ce sont vraiment deux
façons de faire différentes pour créer
de l'image l'argentique elle a un rendu
qui est très spécifique que à titre
personnel j'avais vraiment sensible on a
un grain déjà avant que je fasse du
numérique j'avais été sensible à part
tout ce qui était son rendu vraiment du
grain qu'on peut avoir sur certaines
pellicules en noir et blanc que je
trouve magnifique aujourd'hui ça revient
ça va faire plus de 5-6 ans qu'on dit
que c'est à la mode je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est plus à la mode
parce que la mode normalement était fait
mère donc aujourd'hui pour moi c'est
inscrit vraiment comme une discipline à
part entière et lâche-moi ça pour but du
coup de pouvoir proposer des boîtiers
réviser garantis qui vont pas planter
parce qu'il faut savoir que les boîtiers
ils ont en général une cinquantaine
d'années comme une bagnole il faut les
réviser les revu les regrets etc pour
que justement ils puissent produire de
une photo qui était plus réparable et
pour ceux qui veulent se mettre à
l'argentique le site Internet propose
des appareils reconditionnés pourquoi
l'argentique parce que c'est un moyen
qui permet de faire de l'image qui va
vraiment avoir une authenticité on va
avoir un rendu qui est très particulier
qu'on va pas retrouver en numérique je
crois de manière plus large que
l'argentique dans un contexte de
création artistique parce qu'il a des
contraintes comme le dire par rapport au
numérique on peut monter en sensibilité
faire un peu tout et n'importe quoi
l'argentique a des contraintes mais des
contraintes nées la créativité la
l'expérience utilisateur est différente
on va vraiment prendre son temps
réfléchir avant de déclencher parce que
quand même ça coûte cher une photo en
argentique pour la réparation d'un
appareil photo argentique qu'il faudra
compter entre 150 et 200 euros et un
délai d'environ trois semaines prochaine
objectif pour Adrien ouvrir sa boutique
sur Paris